Three drop mana rocks are crap. Years
ago, this used to be the lukewarm take
in commander that I didn't quite agree
with. I mean, look at dark steel ingot
is pretty much like ramping a land,
right? And commander sphere early game
mana late game Kentrip. The lockets
aren't terrible either. Yeah, this was
way back. But since then, Wizards has
shown me over and over how off I was
with my card evaluation by tacking more
and more utility onto these three mana
rocks, proving just how underpowered
they were for most of Commander's
history. And now we need a closer look
at these rocks because they've
maintained the floor of three mana at
one, but offer so much varied utility
that it's getting difficult to write
them off. And you're welcome to join me.
This is Jyn with Next Level Commander.
My apologies for the lack of updates in
the past 2 weeks. I was a bit caught up
with life and work. Speaking of work,
this channel is only around 99,000
subscribers away from becoming a
full-time gig. So, please like and
subscribe and help me get there. Okay.
Anyways, today we're going to look at
some of the most underrated rocks from
the olden days to the newest spoilers
from Avatar. And by underrated, the
definition is simple here. seeing less
play than Dark Steel Ingga, which is a
fine card, but it's getting more and
more difficult to justify playing over
some of these new options. So, Scryfall
for three mana rocks and sort them from
least to most popular. The first one
that pops up is the Waring Triad. Now, I
know the card is kind of new and I think
people are glossing over the mana rock
part and evaluating this as something
else. And to be fair, it does do a lot.
Getting eight cards into the grave isn't
too too difficult, especially in
graveyard decks where this will shine
with its middle ability. A five trample
flying is excellent on offense or
defense. And imagine top decking this in
the late game. Just drop it and smack
someone for five. And interestingly, the
mana ability says target player. So
there are some political implications if
you are the friendly type. And if not,
this also commits crimes. I mean, Giza
and Maressa decks are sleeping on this
according to EDHRE. Don't. It's sweet.
Yeah, we started off with a high bar to
clear, and this is a great example to
show how pushed these modern-day
manaliths are in all the right ways. And
our next candidate is Bliss Ball. I
already kind of made a video about this
one, but to sum it up, this is a mana
rock to power out your commander and
then you can immediately cash it in for
two cards, and that's excellent,
excellent value for decks that are not
green or blue. It also triggers off
opponents attacking each other, so
you'll most likely get to crack it
fairly quickly. The trick here is unlike
commander sphere which you can hold
until the last minute with bliss ball
you want to be aggressive in sacrificing
it. Say you might be missing the next
land drop or two just send it. Combined
with white's small stuff reanimation
theme. This card alone can keep a mono
white or a borrow stack relevant in the
late game single-handedly. Now from the
world of Final Fantasy to Doctor Who
Laser Screwdriver. Now Sonic Screwdriver
is much more popular and is a great
card, but laser feels like it should be
in far more decks. Tapping an artifact
isn't really useful until my friend Alex
warps in a bllight steel classes with
some weird alien commander. I don't
know. But being able to surveil as a
mana sync is excellent and gold at
instant speed is just one of the
strongest abilities you can get on a
rock. This is worth trying in any
non-green deck that operates at instant
speed and bonus points if it cares a bit
about the top deck or the graveyard.
Okay, universes beyond is getting a bit
out of hand. It's finally time for inun.
Just kidding. It's fall out. The
bobbleheads are not really worth
playing. You need two to three on the
battlefield to do anything meaningful.
And that means you need like four or
five in your deck except for one, the
agility bobblehead. Haste and
unblockable is massive in the late game.
And this doesn't even have the dreaded
sorcery speed only cost. Whether it's
turning a late game top deck into an
immediate threat, sending your Voltron
commander in for one final hit, or just
as a political tool, this is worth
another look at. Next up, Progenitor's
Icon. Now, this card isn't exactly
underrated. It's a typo stable, I'm
guessing. But what makes it interesting
is the ability to do work in plenty of
other decks as well. Just being able to
flash a commander in can be invaluable
for plenty of decks. Ones where the
commander is expensive and slow to turn
on while being a removal magnet or decks
that operate mostly at instant speed
where you'd always want to keep your
options open. Also, Voltron commanders
for protection and pseudo haste. The
list goes on. The next one I've been
trying to sell to my play group since
release, but no luck. And I want to hear
your thoughts. The Celestus. Another
card that has utility far beyond the
obvious intended use in werewolf decks.
Getting to loot in one life is excellent
value, especially when it's free.
Switching from day to night can be
difficult, but it's possible if your pot
includes draw players or you happen to
be one yourself. Activating it manually
also isn't the worst option because it's
pretty much a guarantee that someone
will revert it back to day, letting you
two lose and two life. Also, the bonus
of introducing night and day to the
game. I mean, once it's in, it's in.
It's permanent. Just constantly remind
your opponents and make dumb jokes
pointing at your watch. Good times. And
now, if the Celestus is too fiddly for
your liking, the next one is absolute
bomb. All fate squirrel. I'm tempted to
call this the strongest three mana rock
in commander, but I'm not even sure I
should be evaluating this as a mana
rock. It's like a blue sun zenith
attached to a rock for any color. No,
you don't even need to be playing a land
stack or a ton of colors. I mean, I
immediately swapped this in for
commander fierce in all of my Boros
decks. And by the time you crack it,
it's easily five to seven cards.
Expensive to activate, yes, but taking a
turn off to completely refill your hand
is a luxury that many less privileged
decks have never seen before. even in
monocolored. Heck, even in colorless.
This is like causal like levels of card
draw in the late game. All on a mana
rock. And to round things out, we have a
card yet to be released from Avatar.
Benders water skin. This is the kind of
card that many need to play to see its
value. But imagine a control deck that
operates at instant speed. A commander
sphere will net you five mana on turn
four, but Bender's Water Skin can
potentially be three mana on your turn,
plus three more on your opponent's turn,
and another one after that. Insane value
in decks that can maximize it. Also
worth mentioning, I do enjoy a lot of
decks that are overly dependent on a
powerful commander, backed up by
protection, of course. For example, Both
and Baritl. I built him with Noble
Heritage as the background, and the goal
is to keep Both around and never having
to worry about combat again and
eventually kill people with Both Voltron
damage. Seems good. But the entire game
plan falls apart without Bale. Now, bail
I normally don't drop until I have six
mana, five for casting and one to keep
it alive for the turn. Bender's water
skin allows me to reach this point two
turns early, making it one of the best
cards to see in the opening hand, I
imagine. Now, can three drop mana rocks
really compete with two drops? I am not
sure. Probably not. Because because no
matter how fancy they are and how high
they push the ceilings of these cards,
we have to evaluate them based on the
floor. And these are mana rocks. We want
them to make mana. It's almost like
lands that entertap versus the ones that
don't. There's no comparison. And the
difference between two and three mana
rocks is massive if you think about it
because they produce a mana. So the net
cost for arcing signate is actually one
while commander sphere costs two. That's
double. And this is why you can often
times sneak in an arcing signant or a
talisman without disrupting your turn
too much. But it's much more difficult
or precisely twice as difficult to do
that with three mana rocks. But all
things considered, I think it's
wonderful that Wizards has realized the
need to push three mana rocks and going
ham with it in the past couple of years.
And finally, many of them are actually
worth another look alongside your Arcing
Signness and Talisman. Are there some
other hidden gems which I've glossed
over? Please let me know in the
comments. This is Jyn with Next Level
Commander. I do a lot of deck tags and
random hidden gem videos like this one.
And in the future, I'm looking to do
some gameplay videos which can be very
exciting. So yeah, if you enjoy this
content and look forward to more, please
like and subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video.